اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
اليوم بالاجماع القرار المعنون اليوم
العالمي للنمر العربيه الذي قدمته المملكه
وشارك في رعايته اكثر من 30 دوله حدد
القرار الذي قدمه مندوب المملكه الدائم
لدى الامم المتحده
السفير عبد العزيز الواصل يوم العاشر من
فبراير يوم العالميا للنمر العربي حيث يتم
الاحتفال به سنويا يصلي القرار الضوء على
النمر العربي كونه احد اكثر انواع النمور
المهدده بالانقراض ويؤكدوا على اهميته
لحمايه الحياه البريه والتنوع البيولوجي
من العلا ينضم الينا رئيس قطاع التواصل
والعلاقات العامه في الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلي عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن حياك
الله معي 10 فبراير اذا هو اليوم العالمي
للنمر العربي حسب الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده كيف تم الوصول لهذه النتيجه
استاذ خالد مشاهدي العربيه طبعا اول شيء
نتقدم باسمه الشكر والتهنئه لسوق سيدي ولي
العهد رئيس اداره الهيئه الملكيه محافظه
العلا لانه الاهتمام بكل الملفات البيئيه
وعلى راسها النمر العربي اللي هو اعلى
المستهدفه المفترسات في الجزيره العربيه
كانوا من البدايه كان في عده خطوات
الحقيقه على المستوى البيئي وعلى المستوى
ايضا اللوجستي ورفع الوعي بالنمر العربي
اللي ابدا بمساله الوعي كان في عده
مبادرات وفي تعاون مع عده منظمات منها
الاتحاد والحفاظ على البيئه وبانثيرا
ومؤسسه كاتبوسفير التي تراسها سمو سفيره
خادم الحرمين في في واشنطن ثم اتى ايضا
دعم اضافي من الحكومه في بدايه العام
المنصرم عبر تحديد 10 فبراير كيل كيوم
للنمر العربي
واحتفلنا فيه في العام الماضي في هذا
العام واليوم تاتي هذه الخطوه الحقيقه
تتويجا بحيث يكون يوما عالميا يرفع وعيه
على مستوى العالم وهو من اهم الكائنات
الحيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجزيره العربيه بشكل كامل وما هي
الطبيعه الجهود التي قامت بها الهيئه
الملكيه محافظه العلا
للمحافظه على بيئه النمر العربي في
المملكه
النمر العربي بالنسبه لنا هو هو دره التاج
عندما ان شاء الله يعاد اطلاقه في
المحميات في العلا كان هناك عده خطوات
لاعاده النظم البيئيه اولا حدد اكثر من
نصف مساحه محافظه العلا لتكون خمس محميات
طبيعيه ما يزيد على 12 الف كيلو متر من
ضمن حوالي 22 الف وهي مساحه محافظه العلا
وهي محميه شرعان بالاضافه الى اربع محميات
ثم اصبح هناك الحفاظا الحقيقه على
النباتات الموجوده النباتات الاصيله وكان
عندنا ايضا حمله تشجير
حقه 120 الف نبته منذ العام 2019
ولديها حق نسبه بقاء مرتفعه مقارنه
بالمعدلات العالميه وهي تسعه وثمانين في
المئه نسبه ما يبقى من هذه الاشجار ثم
بالاضافه الى ذلك وبالتعاون مع الحياه
الفطريه وعده مؤسسات في المملكه وفي دول
الخليج تم اطلاق عده عده حيوانات وكان اول
اطلاق مله سمو سيدي في فبراير 2019